we get back for our top story tonight as
we mentioned in our opening monologue
Robert molars team on defense tonight
really serious claims the FBI pressuring
general Flynn to be interviewed without
an attorney present well that has now
got the attention of US District Judge
Emmett G Sullivan he's now ordered
mauler to hand over all documents
related to the Flint interview by 3:00
p.m. tomorrow and on top of that then
you have James Comey on tape boasting oh
we totally took advantage of the fact
that this is a new administration we
were gonna have done this in the Obama
or Bush years really here to discuss it
more Ohio Congressman Jim Jordan and the
host of Sinclair's full measure
Cheryl Atkinson is with us this is how
we treat American heroes that we now
brag oh this is something that I
wouldn't have done or gotten away with a
more organized administration like the
Obama administration and the Bush
administration so I took full advantage
on top of the deputy FBI director
telling Flynn he doesn't need a lawyer
and that they wanted him relaxed
meanwhile because of the unmasking and
leaking of raw intelligence something by
the way cheryl atkinson knows pretty
much about personally they had a direct
transcript that they shouldn't have had
congressman okay yeah when does this end
and one of these people get held
accountable instead of the people with
the taxi medallions and the lower half
Haitians well that's why we've always
said we need a second special counsel
because you know we can't put anyone
jail we can just try to get answers but
you're so right Sean when you have when
you say I got away with something that
just tells you you didn't do it the
right way you didn't do it you didn't
follow the rules you didn't do it the
way you were supposed to they were so
focused on getting president getting
president Trump that they were willing
to set up a lieutenant general a guy who
served our country as you said 33 years
so that's the most that's the most
egregious part of this what they did to
general Flynn the other thing I think
it's important to understand is Mike
Flynn ran the Defense Intelligence
Agency he had to know his conversations
with kids lyac were being listened to
were being monitored so he had to know
that there's no reason for him to come
in there and say something that wasn't
true he just got caught because he
didn't know they were setting him up
like they did and so Judge Sullivan
demanding these doctor
is exactly what needs to happen the
dynamic trio call me McCabe and struck
cheryl atkinson you could relate this
you can relate to this i'm sure in your
own way especially on masking
surveillance issues but more importantly
i can't believe this has happened in our
country I don't care where you stand on
the political spectrum I think you're
getting at what I think is the bigger
story really and is underreported in
terms of how big it really is which is
this surveillance and other alleged
abuses implemented by some bad actors in
our intelligence community and the
problem is you know I'm glad if judge
Sullivan is flirting around the edges of
this in the Flynn case but who
ultimately does anything about it
because those accused as in the
government computer intrusions to me or
other things that we've talked about are
the ones who have the prosecutorial
authority if they're not going to agree
to investigate themselves and prosecute
themselves and so far they haven't then
where do you turn in all this right you
know I don't know how we remedy this
between you go back to Ed they're all
the same characters in this play yeah
and you know it struck and called me
writing an exoneration before
investigation she was guilty biggest
slam dunk obstruction case ever with the
email server and not responding with a
subpoena and erasing and bleach pit and
then of course the FISA abuse
James commis admission Jim Jordan made
it a vetted but he put a signature on
this thing to spy on an opposition party
candidate they've committed fraud
against the FISA Court they don't even
tell the judge you pay for it
so it may have a political taint to it
that is not how things are supposed to
work under this constitution under our
Fourth Amendment rights no you're
exactly right he said in the deposition
last week that he didn't you know that
they had a legal duty if there was a
legal duty to present exculpatory
information to the FISA judge of course
you have to do that for the head of the
FBI to say he didn't know that they
technically had a legal duty to do that
is is is scary the other thing I come
back to Sean is never forget the bias
that exists with these key people McCabe
Komi struck Paige Baker these key people
remember the name they gave the Clinton
investigation mid-year exam something
they had to get through they knew the
fix was in they were going to get it
taken care of it kind of get through the
mid-year exam but what was the name they
gave the Trump Russia investigation
crossfire hurricane just the name show
you the bias that was there from the
get-go with these top people at the FBI
who ran both investigations and Cheryl
they if you look at what they did in in
all of these cases here they're involved
the same characters the same players the
same people that had a bias they did
this on week one of the Trump
administration sounds like an insurance
policy to me sounds like immediately
strategies coming thereafter it sounds
like an operation and something I think
we learned from Comey I mean I thought I
was someone who kind of thought this was
plowing old ground to look back at the
Clinton material but in light of what he
said Kohn we said in his testimony that
Loretta Lynch the Attorney General
should have recused herself and didn't
and was either compromised or appeared
to be not just from the tarmac meeting
but about some other unnamed material we
don't know about number two he says had
he known about agents truck and pages
text messages he wouldn't have let them
stay on the investigation that they
didn't know that's right and they they
wiped clean the phones of Strunk and
Paige when he worked from Fuller and you
know why a question Jeanne ray and
Andrew Weissman and Muller's choice of
his team all Democratic donors this is
why pretty disgraceful